du coup on vient de livrer du charbon
ici pour justement la centrale thermique
de Carlin à l'intérieur du cycle les
dernières phases de test sont en cours
avant le redémarrage de la production
d'électricité à partir du 1er janvier le
ticket de métro parisien coûtera 2,30 €
et le Pass Navigo 90 euros la région
rejette la faute sur l'état accusé de ne
pas l'aider financièrement stoppé en
mars dernier les travaux de maintenance
de la centrale ont repris depuis
quelques semaines
70 salariés ont même été rappelés la
raison un surcoût estimé après d'un
milliard d'euros conséquences de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie une
perspective vivement rejetée par le
gouvernement le gouvernement nous
demande de pré-financer l'exploitation
des quatre lignes de métro du Grand
Paris Express les transports des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et ce sans
aucune recette supplémentaire un jeu de
société qui fait polémique antifa le jeu
n'était plus accessible sur le site de
la Fnac hier l'histoire après avoir été
interpellé par un syndicat de
commissaire et plusieurs élus du
rassemblement national
[Rires]
un jeu inoffensif mais un jeu c'est en
gros on va piocher des cartes qui vont
nous confronter à des événements de
fascistes soirée identitaires agression
homophobe et puis le but ça va être d'y
faire face alors avec des jokers par
exemple un coup de main dans Tifa
d'autres pays des caméras de
vidéosurveillance qui vont aider ou
alors des imprévus qui vont souvenirs
qui vont survenir au contraire type
descente de FAF ou arrivée de la police
nous a même été recommandé en parlait
deux employés de la librairie donc c'est
un jeu qui qui peut se jouer à partir de
14 ans de 2 à 6 personnes et qui
convient aussi aux personnes qui ont des
forces sensibilités logiques puisque
tout est écrit en écriture inclusive
voici donc le visage de la Chine ce
matin
des barricades érigés par les policiers
pour empêcher tout nouveau RA simplement
des barrières que ces manifestants de
muranes détruisent systématiquement les
autorités chinoises sont confrontées à
un mouvement d'ampleur national inédit
depuis 1989 armée de feuilles blanches
pour dénoncer la censure et de slogan
contre le président seging la population
manifeste contre la politique zéro covid
et ses excès et pourtant la Neuvième
Vague de covid est bien là
3634 quotidiens sur les 7 derniers jours
soit une augmentation de 45%. la Coupe
du monde de football a montré au
téléspectateurs chinois qu'il y avait
d'ailleurs une vie sans masque ni
restriction la télévision censure
désormais les plans de public dans les
stades Caroline caillot quitte le
gouvernement la ministre des
collectivités territoriales à donner sa
démission en raison d'un désaccord avec
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique qui juge sa
déclaration de patrimoine sous-estimé
immense honneur de prendre les fonctions
de PDG à la RATP je consacrerai toute
mon énergie à répondre au défi qui nous
attendent Jean Castex ne croyait sans
doute pas si bien dire en twitant cela
ce matin l'ancien Premier ministre a été
accueilli par une manifestation au siège
social du groupe à Paris tout près de la
gare de Lyon les agents de la
maintenance du réseau ferré protestaient
contre la suppression d'une prime de 300
euros
aujourd'hui donc il peut se déplacer il
vient nous voir et on va bien accueillir
bien sûr pour tenir notre ambition
écologique je constate d'une grande
ambition nationale qui est dans 10
grandes agglomérations 10 grandes
métropoles françaises de développer un
réseau de RER de train urbain c'est se
dire au fond le RER ça n'est pas que sur
Paris dans les 10 principales villes
françaises où il y a thrombose où il y a
trop de circulation ou les déplacements
sont compliqués on doit se doter d'une
vraie stratégie de transport urbain
allez
voilà comment Emmanuel Macron a annoncé
la sortie de sa nouvelle vidéo de
Raiponce aux questions des internautes
sur l'écologie ancien Premier ministre
vient d'être condamné par la Cour des
comptes espagnoles une amende de plus de
275000 € pour désirer d'arrêter dans ses
dépenses de campagne souvenez-vous en
2019 Manuel Valls c'était présenté aux
élections municipales de Barcelone il
avait terminé 4e et donc apparemment il
n'avait pas déclaré tous ces frais